[Music]
have you ever wondered how digital
devices are able to connect us to the
world data centers are the engines that
power the technology to make it all
happen these buildings full of computers
store and process all of the information
that we access
online Google data centers play a vital
role in building a growing connected and
sustainable world for
everyone Google is committed to working
with local communities to build the
necessary infastructure of tomorrow to
support connection digitization and
prosperity where it's most
needed as we build our data centers we
are taking bold action to protect the
environment with a goal that by 2030 all
of our data centers will run on clean
energy 24 hours a day 365 days a year
when Google invests in our own
infrastructure we also invest in the
communities around us we build lasting
relationships with local organiz Gan
ation so that our support in the form of
Grants education programs and other
initiatives aligns with local needs and
priorities we work with Partners in our
community like schools nonprofits and
small businesses to help bring better
jobs more skills training and of course
technology access We Believe by being
stewards of the community and the
environment we can all help build a
resilient future
[Music]
together